[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité n'a plus l'âge d'être
considéré comme un jeune premier au
cinéma et pourtant tout le monde le voit
encore avec son sourire enjoleur de
trentenir dans les randonneurs ù la
vérité siement notre invité n'a pas
encore l'âge d'être considéré comme un
monument du cinéma français et pourtant
là aussi ils sont rares ceux qui peuvent
se vanter d'avoir joué dans le mythique
péril jeune de Cédric klapich à jamais
gravé dans l'esprit et le cœur de
plusieurs millions de Français ni jeune
premier ni monument et surtout pas
démodé même pour la nouvelle génération
il arrive à incarner des personnages de
référence dont on répète les répliques
ou ou dont on imite les guimiic comme
ériic Perez dans BRI la série de Jérémy
guz car notre invité oui fait partie des
acteurs qui acceptent le transfert du
grand au petit écran l'alternance entre
cinéma plateforme et bonne vieille télé
et ce n'est pas si fréquent qu'est-ce
qui le guide dans ses choix qu'est-ce
qui le porte il aime jouer alors il joue
c'est peut-être aussi simple que cela
posons-lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un mondeun regard et
bienvenue à vous Vincent elbase merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
Sénat au tn dans ce décor magnifique
qu'est-ce qui vous guide dans vos choix
de rôle est-ce que c'est un feeling avec
un réalisateur est-ce que c'est un
scénario c'est une question complexe et
une alchimie c'est tout ça tout ça à la
fois ou oui une histoire un scénario un
rôle et et la proposition de départ qui
est toujours la même
jouer jouer il y a quelque chose de
ludique auquel je peux j'ai du mal à
résister dans cette proposition et vous
aimez tout jouer ça peut être le
dragueur des rondonneurs comme le le le
voyou dans dans BRI ça peut être est-ce
qu'avec l'âge vous commencez à vous
interroger davantage sur vos choix de
rôle est-ce que vous interdisez des
rôles peut-être j'aime tout jouer mais
pas n'importe quoi
h voilà avec l'âge ça évolue ou pas du
tout c'est les les propositions qui
évoluent c'est les propositions qui
évoluent ce sont ce qu'on sont les
scénarios qu'on propose avec les oui
dernièrement effectivement ce rôle
secondaire là dans une série sur la
brigade de question d'intervention ouais
on proposait ce ce ce malfrra gitan que
c'est une communauté que je connais pas
c'est un monde que je connaissais pas ça
m'a intéressé de de l'explorer quoi euh
de l'explorer à fond ouais voilà il y a
une curiosité pour d'autres univers
d'autres rôles que vous n'avez pas
encore joué il y a il y a cette
motivation là oui oui oui oui il y a
plein plein d'univers que j'aimerais
explorer le monde politique par exemple
par que c'est un univers qui m'est
complètement étranger euh h je je je
n'ai jamais à ma connaissance rencontré
d'homme politique par exemple euh je
c'est un monde
très très à part pour moi enfin c'est
c'est c'est assez fascinant euh
euh les rages du pouvoir l'exercice du
pouvoir c'est intéressant euh qu'est-ce
qui vous fascine dans cette dans cet
univers oh c'est cette phrase d'un
esséiste d'un philosophe il me semble
qui s'appelle Jean-Claude Milner ouais
et qui avait écrit ce un bouquin qui
s'appelle la politique des êtres
parlants je crois mais il il disait dans
ce bouquin il me semble que c'est dans
ce bouquin d'ailleurs euh le la
politique c'est l'école des émotions et
le couple c'est l'école de la politique
et cette phrase m'avait frappé sur les
deux plans c'est-à-dire à la fois euh le
le le rapport amoureux comme école de la
politique Natur non et et cette phrase
elle me elle revient souvent dans dans M
scénario
quand je sais pas quand oui quand il a
j'aborde des des de rapports de couple
ou ou et c'est alors la politique ça oui
oui dans comme école des émotions
c'est-à-dire cette confrontation au réel
ou à la réalité ou aux événements qui
qui les percute quoi et notamment ou ou
ne serait-ce que la campagne électorale
par exemple c'est c'est euh avec des
vrais rôles à jouer presque du mensonge
à formuler on est quand même dans des
promesses dont on sait que parfois ou
oui oui ça c'est le rôle ça c'est le
mais la rencontre le le avec le réel
c'estàd le quand on se cogne on se cogne
à la réalité cette ce moment où ça per
on se percute c'est ça l'école des
émotions je je crois je l'interprète
comme ça quand les politiques sont sont
percutés par voilà quand ils se cognent
dans quelque chose qui est qui est voilà
alors ça peut être évidemment des choses
tragiques hein comme les attentats comme
mais gen je pensais à par exemple à à au
à la période du covid h quand le
discours très libéral un peu économie
libérale de Macron se transforme en un
discours hyper social par exemple h
euh j'écoutais comme tout le monde à la
télé le soir ses interventions les
interventions le nombre de morts du
covid enfin ce truc un peu un peu
mortifère parfois mais les interventions
et le le j'étais étonné de voir à quel
point il y avait un un changement
de je m'étais dit tiens bah c'est
peut-être ça aussi les émotions
traversées qui permettent de se
transformer de s'adapter de je parlais
de ces acteurs qui acceptent de jouer
dans les séries après avoir fait du
cinéma on en préparant cette émission je
me suis rendu compte qu'ils étaient pas
si nombreux que ça est-ce que vous quand
vous franchissez le pas euh votre
entourage vous dit attention on n'y va
pas les plateformes la télévision c'est
pas pour toi est-ce que il y a eu ce
genre de frein ou est-ce que ça y est la
frontière elle est elle est un peu plus
poreuse entre séries et cinéma c'est
presque chic hein même de de jou dans
des séries maintenant c'est devenu un
peu c'est différent le regard est
différent euh non ben maintenant les les
les producteurs appelle les agents pour
des films et puis on leur répond bah il
peut pas il est il est pris par sa
série c'est pas honteux de le dire il a
sa série il peut plus là et c'est plus
honteux de le dire euh non c'est plus
honteux de le dire mais c'est ça devient
problématique quoi parce que ça prend du
temps une série donc les enemplois du
temps se se télescope ou ouais mais il y
a une richesse d'écriture dans les S a
un peu
romanesque le côté roman nouvel qui se
qui se avec les les suites quoi enfin
voilà c'est il y a une richesse
d'écriture je trouve dans grand sé j'ai
envie de creuser avec vous effectivement
qu'est-ce qui change pour le pour
l'acteur pour son jeu d'acteur d'être
dans une série ou ou dans un film moi
j'ai pas encore fait the wire ou Les
Soprano ce genre de chos he donc ça
c'est c'est ce que j'appelle vraiment
les grandes séries qui d'accord qui
portent un regard sur l'humain la
société euh presque philosophique quoi
enfin presque voilà euh j'ai pas j'ai
pas eu accès à ça encore mais mais par
contre j'ai trouvé dans BRI ou dans ou
dans dans ou dans des séries françaises
que je regarde le le bureau des légendes
ou ou sur Art certaines très bonnes
séries euh les papillons
noirs récemment enfin c'est c'est une
très c'est il y a une richesse
d'écriture ouais qui est proche du roman
je trouve avec je ressens la même chose
que quand je lis un roman face à une
très bonne série mais au-delà de ça la
cadence le rythme on dit que c'est
toujours quand même ah tourner voulez
direou tour un acteur oui à tourner ça
rien à voir oui c'est sûr c'est oui
c'est pas ah bah la série moi ça m'a
appris une chose c'est l'amour des
plateau de
cinéma pourquoi bah parce que c'est le
plateau d'une série c'est c'est super
mais enfin
c'est disons qu'un metteur en scène
ou un ou un show Honner de série h peut
pas arriver sur le plateau le matin en
disant finalement ce ce décor je v pas
le filmer comme ça on va faire un peu
autrement si on pouvait repeindre cette
porte en rose parce que non ça c'est pas
possible sur un un film d'auteur je
pense que c'est possible c'est possible
d'arriver le matin et d'avoir même si on
est très préparé d'avoir une sorte de
d'inspiration nouvelle qui qui réoriente
le la séquence la sur série c'est plus
c'est plus compliqué ouais mais vous
direz que ça obéit même à des logiques
un peu marketing il faut être un peu
spectaculaire dans son jeu plus que dans
le cinéma où on va chercher la subtilité
quand on est acteur ou pas euh c'est
c'est juste que la façon de fabriquer
une série et de l'écrire et de la
produire je suis pas producteur mais je
je pense qu'il se les producteurs de
séries se heurtent
euh au au diffuseur plus le process
avance et plus le plus les demandes
elles peuvent être du côté du mainstream
de quelque chose de plus de plus de plus
consensuel et cetera et je pense qu'ils
sont ils sont
le cinéma d'auteur c'est pas ça le
cinéma d'auteur c'est il y a un scénario
un producteur un metur en scène un
auteur qui écrit et et ensuite une fois
qu'il y a le scénario ils vont trouver
l'argent il y a pas il y a pas ce ce
temps long d'attendre des des green
light des feux verts pour tel écriture
puis tel épisode put c'est et quand on
est acteur est-ce qu'on doit être
toujours dans la séduction est-ce qu'on
doit toujours essayer de provoquer le
coup de cœur chez un réalisateur un
producteur ou est-ce que quand on a
votre notoriété on cherche plus à faire
ça on est comme on est et on nous prend
comme on est ou est-ce que c'est
compliqué d'être dans cette position
d'acteur où on doit donner envie on doit
provoquer le désir je vais pas montrer
forcément
euh
mes comment dire maises mes faces les
plus intimes non les plus qui pourraient
poser problèm sur un plateau ouais je
vais plutôt montrer
le c'est pour ça que je crois pas
tellement au casting par exemple ah bon
mais non parce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
savoir de de de de la la vérité de
quelqu'un pendant un casting un casting
c'est vouloir le job donc bon quand je
veux le job je fais le casting et je le
fais le mieux possible et et je montre
tout les meilleures facettes deou de mon
jeu ou de de moi ça vous arrive encore
desis ça m'est pas arrivé depuis un
moment mais je veux dire ça m'était
arrivé ça m'est arrivé et et on montre
pas
forcément c'estile de de de montrer qui
on est vraiment en casting moi j'ai
jamais considéré qu'il fallait plaire à
tout prix mais mais par contre
surprendre aller chercher en soi des
ressources qui qui
surprennent qui se enfin se surprendre
soi-même ça ça ça se se laisser aller
dans un processus qu'on maîtrise pas
forcément et qui surprennent le l'œil du
météo en scène sur le plateau ou ou son
partenaire ou sa partenaire et qui
surprennent aussi des choix qui
surprennent le spectateur c'est prover
la petite lumière dans le regard oui
c'est ça moi ça j c'est ça si vous si
c'est ça être dans essayer de séduire le
le public oui peut-être du côté de la
surprise vous vous l'avez déclenché le
coup de cœur plusieurs fois avec Cédric
lapich qui vous offre votre premier rôle
au cinéma avec John malkovic aussi qui
vous a dirigé au théâtre deux fois je
crois la belle aventure humaine vous
l'avez aussi vécu avec la vérité
sigement ce sont même les producteurs du
péril jeune qui vous proposent de faire
partie du casting vous dites oui pour le
de la vérité siement non pour le 2 mais
ils reviennent à la charge pour le 3 ils
insistent ils vous veulent vraiment un
peu comme pour enfin c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti en lisant tout cela un peu
comme pour reconstituer une sorte de
famille et vous cédez parce que vous
êtes touché c'est ce que j'ai lu dans
vos interviews c'est qu'à la fin vous
dites bon bah s'ils me veulent vraiment
c'est que quand même peut-être ils
m'aiment bien c'est aussi ça quand même
le monde du cinéma il y a quand même une
affaire d'amitié voire de famille alors
oui ouais et non ah c'estàd que oui
faridissa on avait un un lien très fort
parce que ce sont les producteurs du
péril jeune j'avais pas besoin du deux
ouais donc je l'ai pas fait en fait
j'avais pas besoin du 2 j'en voulais pas
j'en voulais pas et je leur avais dit je
me souviens même le soir de
l'avant-première du
1 on va faire une suite et tout je dis
ouais ça sera sans moi les gars pourquoi
parce que donc je sais pas pourquoi
j'avais sûrement une angoisse à l'idée
deêtre enfermé dans un truc de de juif
sphara je sais pas de d'ov de je je au
final je pense que ça aura rien changé
que je le fasse ou pas au fond mais bon
je l'ai pas fait et
euh j'ai tout fait pour pas le faire
c'estàdire dire non refuser demander
beaucoup d'argent pour pas le faire au
final ils disent oui enfin bon donc ça
s'est transformé en une sorte de de
rendez-vous où on s'est vu tous les
trois et où ils sont devenus où il où
ils m'ont regardé en disant mais tu es
complètement con quoi tu nous dis non
quoi mais on est resté euh finalement on
est resté lié et le 3 euh le 3 j'en
avais besoin à quel niveau euh bah je
sortais d'une série qui s'appelle No
limite produite par Bisson euh et ça
faisait 3 ans que je faisais plus de
cinéma donc
euh
je je pense que j'en avais besoin enfin
j'avais besoin de d'un film comme ça
grand public euh euh populaire vous avez
l'air d'aimer les films de bande quand
même de bande de copains de groupe c'est
un hasard ou ou c'est aussi parce queil
y a un côté sympa de de de se fondre
dans le groupe il y il y a quelque chose
que vous allez chercher dans ce groupe
la vérité siement le les rendhonneur
tout ça c'est du ouais oui c'est vrai
non mais j'ai débuté dans les films de
groupe ouais euh c'est oui les le
périonneur la vérité c'est vrai c'est ça
c'est le super copain d'une super bande
de copains qu'on a tous envie d'avoir
ouou oui j'ai trouvé ma place facilement
dans les dans les dans les les bandes
peut-être euh il esprit de troupe je
pense que je doisir un esprit un peu de
partage comme ça j'aime bien partager
j'ai pas de problème à partager le
générique ouais et laffiche laaffiche ou
de pas être sur laffiche ou d' être
enfin c'est tout ça n'a pas très
beaucoup d'importance pour moi vous
mettez peu d'ego en fait dans finalement
si j'en ai non non j'ai de l'ego mais
l'ego je le mets entre action et coupé
quoi c'est-à-dire que entre action et
coupé
je je laisse libre cours à à toutes mes
mes impulsions de jeu et et je prends la
je prends la place qui m'est donnée pas
plus mais je la j'essaie de la remplir
et puis surtout je prends une
liberté si ça plaît pas il coupe on
refait autre chose mais je je m'autorise
tout toutes les libertés possibles entre
action et coupé CH Oui mais après le le
oui je non mais c'est vrai que les films
de groupe c'était chouette c'était super
euh j'ai pas de problème avec avec ça
puis je pense que je au départ je me
voyais faire du théâtre moi pas
tellement de cinéma en fait donc c'était
l'esprit de troupe euh esprit de groupe
et puis non puis j'ai j'ai besoin de
l'autre pour pour jouer j'ai besoin de
ça vous a pénalisé dans votre carrière
de pas forcément vouloir être tout en
haut de la fiche et de d'accepter
justement cette place qu'on vous donne
pas plus je vais pas prendre un scénario
pas bon parce que il y a le rôle
principal quoi je bien sûr ça ça ça
me c'est d'ailleurs c'est pas
très je pense que c'est dommageable pour
un acteur de de faire trop de rôles
principaux dans des films pas bons j'ai
une archive à vous proposer Vincent
Elbas vous allez la découvrir en même
temps que le public et je vais la lire
pour ceux qui nous écoutent c'est une
archive délivrée par nos partenaires les
archives national il s'agit d'un mot
collé à la porte d'une salle de la
Sorbonne pendant le mouvement étudiant
de Mai 68 avis au flic est-il écrit
cette salle a été utilisée par le
mouvement étudiant travailleur votre
arrivée est inutile vous n'y trouverez
rien d'intéressant pour votre appétit
fasciste vous n'êtes que des pentins
ridicules incapablees d'une réflexion
intelligente imbécile
révolutionnaireement vôtre je montre
cela à l'enfant d'ex 68ard je crois que
votre mère a occupé la Sorbonne même oui
euh qu'elle a jeté des pavé sur les CRS
est-ce que ça dit quelque chose de vous
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça a forgé dans
l'adulte que vous êtes devenu cet esprit
68 dans lequel vous avez été quand même
un peu élevé oui oui oui oui très
extrême gauche quoi euh
euh bah quand j'avais 18 20 ans je
dirais que j'étais très euh ouais très
très euh très extrême gauche d'accord
mais alors moi à 18 20 ans l'extrême
gauche si vous voulez c'est plus la même
que celle de ma mère trotkist liniste
des années 60 je je sais pas j'ai pas
adhéré à aucun mouvement ou j'ai pas été
du proactif mais en tant qu'acteur euh
à l'époque enfin un jeune acteur enfin
qui prenait des cours de théâtre
j'allais souvent voir le théâtre de
l'opprimée c'était un une compagnie de
théâtre qui venait du Brésil ou de
l'Argentine je crois qui qui qui jouait
à l'époque dans les favellas et cetera
pour et qui avait donné un spectacle sur
Ralet Kelkal ah oui et pour moi à
l'époque Ralet
Kelkal
c'était le GIA l'islamisme et l'extrême
gauche je voyais Ralet Kelkal comme un
un révolutionnaire
euh religieux politique et religieux
mais du côté religieux du côté spirituel
et donc je voyais je voyais dans
l'islamisme un mouvement euh qui
s'apparentait pour moi au au mouvement
trotskist
léiniste que j'avais en fantasme du côté
de effectivement de ma mère a 68 Ardes
et donc j'avais été saisi par ce
spectacle où il y avait un je un acteur
qui jouait Ralet Kelkal impliqué dans
les attentats de
95 qui est un terroriste qui avait fait
les attentats de 95 dans le RB à
Saint-Michel qui avait tué beaucoup de
monde et donc j'avais envie de jouer ça
et et donc je m'étais procuré le texte
dans l'intégralité du du du du
du finalement des interviewsav hm hm et
en lisant intégralité
euh j'avais été euh
heurté parce que le SP dans le spectacle
il n'avait pas retranscrit euh je suis
tombé dans enfin sur le texte intégral
je suis tombé sur Ralet Kelkal qui parle
des Juifs
ah et là ça a été un choc pour moi parce
que j'étais euh j'étais très euh je
voyais ce mouvement comme un mouvement
révolutionnaire euh qui voulait de
manière spirituelle utiliser la religion
à des fins politiques quoi et là je
voyais pas de mal à ça cette utilisation
politique du religieuxou j'avais 18 ans
j'étais très antiystème et cetera quoi
et alors la la haine des Juifs dans les
les les
témoignages quelcal mavait complètement
déstabilisé parce que je m'attendais pas
à ça je comprenais même pas ça je
comprenez pas ce quel rapport il y avait
entre un idéal révolutionnaire entre un
idéal révolutionnaire effondrait un
système
capitaliste quit à faire des attentats
et cetera comme la bande abader l'avait
fait et cetera et la haine des Juifs la
haine des Juifs et c'est là que ça vous
et ça ça m'a complètement réveillé
c'est-à-dire que je suis passé de
l'extrême gauche à à à ça m'a
complètement ouvert les yeux sur
l'extrême gauche et sur
ce
oui cette d'un coup les les finalement
les les les les les gens que j'aimais me
haissit en fait
euh ça ça il y avait pas évidemment que
ma fascination pour de quelcal mais il y
avait aussi celle pour les leaders
d'extrême gauche les mouvements et et ça
ça m'a ça m'a éveillé ma conscience
c'est que ça veut dire que le comédien
que vous étiez que vous êtes j'ai pas
fait le spectacle voilà ne pourrait et
ne pourrait toujours pas jouer ce genre
de rôle ah si je pourrais jouer un
terroriste non mais al ça ça pas c'est
un autre problème je pourrais jouer un
pédophile un terroriste tout ce que vous
voulez j'ai j'ai pas de morale là-dessus
j' rien à secouer c'est c'est je vais je
vais si je dois incarner
euh
l'inhumanité pas un extraterrestre mais
l'inhumanité c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui
est un être humain qui se comporte de
manière inhumaine j'ai aucun problème
pour le faire
mais mes positions euh
à l'époque ont changaé politiquement
quoi à ce moment-là c'est-à-dire c'est
cette rencontre avec l'antisémitisme de
l'extrême gauche qui
m'a qui m'a un peu ouvert les yeux
quoi moi j'ai des photos en attendant
notamment celle-ci je sais pas si vous
le connaissez il s'appelle kabyim c'est
un tiktokeur Italien qui est devenu une
star dans le monde entier grâce à des
vidéos drôles euh peut-être que vous
n'êtes pas sur TikTok mais les enfants
le sont justement en 2022 pas enfants
mais on va en parler parce qu'en 2022
dans le monde les enfants de 4 à 18 ans
ont passé en moyenne 1h47 par jour sur
TikTok plus de 4h par jour au total
devant des écrans et c'est un peu la
question vous qui avez quatre enfants
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites sur les
écrans est-ce que vous mettez des
limites je suis de plus en plus inquiet
effectivement
euh pour mes enfants
euh je je je vais essayer de donner le
bon exemple déjà d'accord je vais
essayer parce que moi-même je suis en
relation euh
organique avec mon portable donc c'est
si vous voulez c'est comme tout le monde
quoi c'est ouis dire com on est un peu
tous ben oui c'està-dire que
je je je il faut j'essaie de je suis
dans la croyance qu'il faut dominer
cette c'est àiction on peut parleric ou
mais c'est mais c'est l'addiction c'est
encore un terme un peu light pour pour
décrire pour décrire ce ce ce ce qui ce
qui ce qui nous arrive là je
trouve je donc je vais essayer de donner
le bon exemple concrètement en fait euh
je vais je vais proposer je propose
d'acheter des CD h pour éviter les
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans la sélection
automatique de ce qui nous S qui ce qui
est censé nous plaire en musique c'estàd
qu'ils font faire aucun effort de fait
plus aucun effort de de recherche quoi
de et d'ouverture ouais ouais oui il y a
plus aucun effort qui fait pour fer dans
le pour aller chercher des trucs euh
c'est tout vient à à nous de
manièreou très euh artificiel
oui artificiel et c'est des sont des
désirs qui deviennent artificiels c'est
même l'absence de désir en fait donc je
vois par exemple
oui oui j'ai peur de de de découvrir une
absence de désir chez mes enfants par
exemple ça c'est une angoisse c'est
l'absence de désir de de d'imaginaire de
de curiosité sur le monde et tout ça ça
c'est vraiment un truc qui
qui qui vous inquiète oui la façon dont
les les téléphones répondent à nos à nos
demande immédiate sans forcément
réfléchir beaucoup c'est ouais ça ça
m'angoisse vachement pour les pour les
mes
enfants donc bon ouais je sais pas quoi
faire c'est un peu démuni lutter à notre
renseigne je me renseigne je suis en
train de lire un bouquin là-dessus
savoir quoi faire j'ai une deuxième
photo euh alors il s'agit de l'affiche
du film anatomie d'une chute palme d'or
à Cann euh je fais un blocage ce sont
les mots d'Élisabeth borne qui refuse
qui a refusé d'aller voir ce film la
première ministre parce que la
réalisatrice Justine Triet a critiqué la
politique gouvernementale notamment avec
le le le monde artistique
eu quel regard vous portez sur ce
boycotte et sur finalement est-ce que ça
veut dire que les réalisateurs ont le
droit de traiter de politique dans leur
films mais pas d'en parler ou comment
vous voyez ça je pense qu'on en a rien à
non c'est-à-dire que ce discours
il a été prononcé mais au fond tout le
monde s'en branle non j'ai l'impression
enfin moi ça m'a pas percuté enfin elle
elle a oui elle a je sais pas moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est son film en fait c'est
son film quoi voilà moi ça pas son
discours àade m'a pas du tout empêcher
de enfin couper du désir de voir ce ce
film qui a l'air désir encore vous en
parlez beaucoup ou l' extraordinaire ce
film enfin j'ai très envie de le voir
j'ai hâte je pense qu'il joue encore
j'ai une dernière question qui est en
lien avec le lieu dans lequel nous nous
trouvons Vincent base nous sommes
entourés de quatre statutes qui
représentent chacune une vertu vous avez
la sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence laquelle de ces vertus vous
caractérise le plus ou vous parle le
plus me caractérise non mais je
choisiraai le courage qui n'est pas là
ouais mais vous avez le droit d'en
choisir une autre le courage le courage
de de
h mais c'est pas ça me caractérise pas
hein mais je je j'admire cette vertu là
quelle oui d'avoir le courage du
discernement voilà ça c'est c'est ça en
fait je je choisirai ça malheureusement
je elles sont pas là mais la prudence
non la justice bon oui évidemment hein
le sentiment de justice mais et courage
et discernement c'est intéressant ple
idéologies qui sont cachées derrière le
l'idéal de justice et qui qui on bon
voilà
qui sont qui en onont pas fait une vertu
l'éloquence je je j'admire l'éloquence
ça j'admire éedard Bert des gens comme
ça vous savez ouais ouais qui qui sont
des des capable de d'écrire en en direct
d'écrire de manière
cérébrale de créer de l'écriture quoi
par en direct comme ça par les
improvisation on va on va retenir
courage et discernement ce sont vos vos
mots et vos vertus à vous merci merci
beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ici dans ce d
Tournon merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
comme chaque semaine et puis on se
retrouve très très bientôt sur public sa
émission à retrouver en podcast
n'oubliez pas à bientôt
[Musique]
merci